hi my name is Joel Emslie I'm the art
director on titanfall 2 with the
addition of titanfall tues visual
customization we not only have given the
player the opportunity to really
represent themselves and their
personality through the war paints and
the camos and the nose arts of the
titans but we've also given camo
patterns that actually work within the
environments as well so the couple we're
looking at right here is a hollow pilot
combined with Legion and I think what's
kind of cool but what we have going here
is we know we're not trying to be
stealthy about this we're just trying to
go for a really cool camo pattern and
you can kind of have the idea that if
someone sees you they're going to know
your Titan to
so one of my personal combo favorites
that we're looking at right here is a
cloak pilot and then we've got Ronin
behind them with the shark teeth zebra
pattern combo hopefully that zebra
pattern can throw off the reed if you're
moving fast enough which Ronin does get
in there close and personal and go to
the sword
you